Hello, Dr. Kevin Cutters here and we're going to talk about bone cancers, mainly primary
bone cancers in this video, in this section, and a lot of the primary bone cancers are
adolescent or childhood cancers, and it's very scary for parents. It's very scary no
matter what your diagnosis when you hear the word cancer. We understand that. There's
decisions to be made. If it's a child, you really don't have a decision. You're going to have
to go standards of care. We understand that, but adding some alternative care to the process
can give you a better outcome most of the time. So think about how the cancer got there
in the first place. There's very few cancers, bone cancers, one of them that really cares
a genetic base. So we have to look at what can we do to change the milieu, change the environment,
change the terrain. What can we add nutritionally? What can we look at dietarily? That's the alternative
side. If you have to go or you're choosing to go with chemotherapy, radiation, surgery or
something like that, you want to do everything you possibly can to support the body through
that as well. Things that you add from an anti-inflammatory perspective, from a specific
nutrient that can help kill cancer cells can only help the conventional therapies that
you're choosing to do as well. But when you make that choice to add alternative care, it becomes
a daunting task because you're faced with, well, what should I do diet wise? What should
I do with supplement wise? Bioclone has over 100 different supplements that are proven to
be very helpful with different cancers. So when we take on a patient, we test them to get
very specific. We don't want people on 100 different supplements. We want people on four
or five specific things that are going to target their cancer. We don't want to put them
on radical diets either. That's that healthy. That takes all the joy out of your life. We want
to just test for what the fuel source is for that cancer. And then let's eliminate or reduce
that. We test for frequencies with the right. We test for other therapies as well. What's
going to be the best thing to add for you for your cancer? Because ultimately, we want your
success. We want you to improve your odds. We want you to improve the quality of your life
and have a long many years ahead of you. Now ultimately, no matter what you do, whether you choose
to get care with us or not, that's okay. We're going to be praying for you. And we just
ask about that you just put a lot of part of your decision as well.